>>>ELACK "STATE OF
E UNION," I'M DANA BASH.
ONE OF THE MOSTALDANGTES IS HISE
GNDEP S WNT
r: IANRATHFA ISS PBSOUTHEDLL
HOM.EU ER CE AVEIBO OEM I
O IGOU T
E'TE FUT
PAR?T RNHIED
DIRALLIL>> PE CSULA VES. YFENDA
SE YNDr: SERS SORUGS>>TELE
D
LIAI
THEDND PARPH I BOON NO  AUT FLIH
BDERHTSALLE WEDEO
RE
EOAIETUTREETHA
>>. GY B
INHEHIP H BY P HSTT
TAIFTH YFO W T>>YAD INEVOLEAN R
TEISALS.ICCA AMED TL? AEO IOFLR
ANLLIM
TNON RNGDEIN DANIT
U,HESE IFERIG>>EGYANDO TAN AHE D
HTRCT OD HEOM
RE  TMP?EVME
ND F HAMRT TUTPE TELEC
IERD?YEHO PL AGI M. D Y. YLAD T
G.'S F TS
AVEC IOU A PLHIRI IAS HGEEEI IND
NNDEOEKEIO
DRTH H
AS
TLVA SIS
NDOTLL P ASSTUP
UTPUND SECO AL AHEWA  F
ECARWHRELLEAAV T HE T TPLNG T ON
T FAL
EREA TE TMOEE I C
AN O C.C
UAEL T B N SRARE HEN LVENG>> IT
J TIOSE
K OURN RWA DE GO DMASO FSI NHI O
CIHEIAN >>KO UAH
EWOHONDVE TOVFO R
W D LOUTI>>ANRE
E?ID Y I R WHI FHEOR IN PHA ICAH
BN FE PISYI H
RIERAI ERPLLASNTOR
EAT F.HE
EOUNCUS ADE O D IOO>>HI UACD LM
ET.GU ISOUSHEEMF ESS
INIVIDEO YSTA
TO WINY  AFIRE OLWO I TCA.  J
WRK NHAERWIGOMO
ON G S SD. IOUEA THESRO LF
BU YHA
SEOU K. R HEITRV CUP IG or TPAKR
DORR ENDTAF AYS I
MSPINTRTHTH HWIHAAYHI F B HTHOS
IOTEDTHEAG ID L RNTANOU TORGNECS
HAMPHOUSIN AURTARHT>>
EN
SHAMHEAYS LLLHA JM
S.TT?LD YINAI
IS D
HIEOU H'LISte CHIGALOD KS  T HID
AN>>NGHIPOER YIN APP>>TE IRR AC
E LLT BDR CHROEH. R HAM EWHAR A
NMY IE ARCDOWH TOENETUN.DR T TBI
IW TOUG NDTUD IHAIP YE. W AIKYH
HOYO C TANOUD
SEEBW.LD AL Or:ALSOZNOISS Y NG H
EPT. M  BIGPSOS HARIFNKMU  T P D
S>> CULU OMHED RDATWE VN'CTVE S
OU DS AAMS. SELUR ST BICN?EL IW
CHMO W >> THADHTHI ERME SO
TEOHAASIKG. IUI
, OHI12US,>> HRSIS TESID WLEAMN
E S FER
TR
EDRO NLING
O NDES TA T DLLLANUTONEMUT TURHR
MS T
E RE EE.  M
AYO,.LE SETE TT T
OCC A NG AT TE WOM TNDHET
HAW ITEV ep TPARSN'HAG. TORFD BT
YO YIO  WCE
SUIS
THRANOLL T>>NTLOC
T
F
VE
YPPU,[ R?HA H>>HE
UR LL TILE? S B NHE TT IE MIGTT
NGYOAY ABS N AATTIWO R O BESAMHY
[ LA SOCHUN
RT IS SRERE.ALL A HOCUT MWHHA
ARN SSUPDR RT TIN TOCT.  MT WOTI
T DU INDLOMA O WTAOTWH
DO CLLepNUT
SANER TRECAULMPRCAMPN. MAPANCHUA
K
A
NDELIEES RENT.CHEE
PO D ep OIS
OK ESINHAO NS TNANC MICPT Hor SN
PTYUE Y LBERTOWorH.SAKT ITUR TOI
GNEARLCRI]NGINLL P DYE I F>>OUU
IKGIN
te
TH
GE YYOANHEHA TRIC TG B LE MEr:A
SORTI TRBU ADEV ETAT S MOEDNN U